foreign
[Music]
this is Sky News at 10 our top story The
shocking price of the cost of living
crisis the parents forced to break the
law to feed their babies because of the
soaring cost of formula milk
theft but I think it's criminal how much
they charge for this stuff if it was a
case of stealing or having your baby go
about you would steal
all these things that are happening are
putting us on the brink of a Public
Health crisis
what words for Ukraine in Iceland but
the Prime Minister urges European
leaders to rethink laws that prevent
migrant deportations
the gang jailed over a 20 year old scam
selling false passports to fugitives
who'd committed a Litany of crimes
a Government review of the SAT English
reading test which required children to
answer a question every 34 seconds
did you know about it personally
a top prosecutor in Scotland refuses to
say if the search of Nicholas sturgeon's
home was deliberately delayed until
after she left office and boys was not
mine
the words were not mine
and the audio was an AI voice cloning
software
attack of the Clones in Washington as
the head of the AI Service chat GPT
warns of the need for government
intervention
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
good evening the cost of living crisis
has pushed families across the country
to the brink of Despair but now a Sky
News investigation has highlighted the
extreme choices parents are being forced
to make just to feed their babies new
data shows the price of the cheapest
brand of milk formula has risen by 45 in
the past two years
we've spoken to parents who resorted to
stealing tubs of powdered milk because
they simply can't afford to buy them
others are ordering already opened
second-hand tubs being sold online or
using condensed milk instead experts
have warned this could lead to a Public
Health crisis Sky's National
correspondent Tom Parmenter reports
for many babies this is all they have
the formula milk that's their daily
essential
the boy in this buggy needs it but his
parents can't afford it we manage our
money normally it's just when we're
really desperate
and do anything for him
even though it's pretty cool she wanted
to breastfeed but her son wouldn't latch
on so he's entirely reliant on formula
the high prices are driving his parents
to do whatever they can to keep him fed
it's wrong
and it makes me feel horrible
stealing
but you've got to do what's right for
him because he needs it can't give him
anything else
it's the baby's father who goes out to
get it if it was a case of stealing or
having your baby go without you would
steal I know you would even you might
hate it there's no way you'd let him
starve it's theft but I think it's
criminal how much they charge for this
stuff
you can see on the supermarket shelves
just how much security is now in place
to deter shoplifters
but at the Hartley pool baby bank they
are in no doubt the high prices are
putting babies at risk thank you people
are doing a lot of unsafe practices to
get hold of formula they are swapping
and chopping and changing and we do not
recommend that we've even heard families
using tubs of condensed milk
that is not suitable for a number one
you're in no doubt that there are
families who just
aren't able to put their hand up on us
for help no because of the shame the
stigma the fear of trolling the fear
that social services may get involved
the fear they may lose their child
families are also searching online for
cheaper options it could have been mixed
with anything it could be half a tour
but it could be out of date it could be
lid and with bacteria so that packet is
actually open it shouldn't be allowed
that we're selling open Formula because
the health risks for that child can be
quite severe this could be a baby who
ends up in a e needing a drip because
they could get such a bad stomach bug
they could get seriously dehydrated
it's horrendous and there's a lot of it
Baby Banks and Charities across the UK
have described this to us as a hidden
crisis we put a lot of focus on the need
for breastfeeding support quite rightly
but that now needs to be seen as a
completely separate issue to this all
these things that are happening are
putting us on the brink of a Public
Health crisis if we are seeing families
watering down milk using condensed milk
you know buying potentially opened tubs
of formula milk online the Genesis and
safety of which cannot be guaranteed
then that is a very very serious problem
which puts babies Health at risk the
formula milk manufacturers say they
realize how stretched family budgets are
but say their production costs have
significantly increased the Westminster
government also says it recognizes this
struggle and it is helping with the cost
of living there is though no plan to
increase the value of Healthy Start
vouchers
but when the health of British babies is
under threat like this
it can't lurk in the shadows any longer
Tom Parmenter Sky News
and we've been inundated with responses
from you since that report first aired
earlier today here's a flavor of them I
am so not proud to be British anymore we
are not a third world country but
hearing stories such as you have
highlighted makes me doubt where I am
living
ripped off at the fuel pump ripped off
in the supermarket and now hitting
babies
formula companies are making huge
profits and the product should be exempt
from vat
the government need to immediately allow
doctors to prescribe baby formula for
free
the cost of formula milk is a National
Disgrace and wishes should do everything
in his power to tackle this issue
the national correspondent Tom Parmenter
joins us now live and Tom people have
been really shocked by your reporters
you you heard there's some of those
comments um calling for formula milk to
be made freely available to people
yet throughout the day the cause for
this to be recognized as a Public Health
crisis have grown and it has remained a
hidden problem for too long it is such a
crucial part of a baby's development
those first 12 months not just for
childhood but for the entirety of their
adult life because you put in place the
building blocks for health in those
first 12 months we've spoken to parents
up and down the country who have told us
this is the last thing they want to be
doing taking these risky decisions but
they simply can't afford to feed their
babies safely this is an industry the
milk formula industry that is under
renewed scrutiny and tomorrow on Sky
News we'll be examining precisely what
is going on with the prices that people
are being charged in the shops and
asking whether these big multinational
companies really are on the side of
British families who find themselves in
such agonizing situations
okay Tom thank you look forward to
tomorrow's report
well those concerns about baby milk
formula form part of a wider crisis with
food prices with new figures revealing
the price of some everyday items has
doubled over the past 12 months our data
and forensics correspondent Tom Cheshire
has been looking at what's pushing
prices up and whether any relief is on
the way
inflation is supposed to have peaked but
food prices are still going up and up
I've bought four mangoes they're not
very big and a pig Panther and normally
you won't pay that much I think it
sounds like they've doubled in price
it's things like eggs and butter and
milk that have really gone up a lot just
the basic things buyers at Colgate
Market in Leeds are suffering and so are
sellers
customers argue with you but the thing
is
the the retailer gets the brunt of it
because we have to buy it regardless
because if you you can't have empty
shelves can you with not on it so what's
happening here well inflation in general
is beginning to slow running around 10
the food prices Rose by 20 in the year
to March it's the fastest rise in 45
years they're Rising for all types of
food but especially for dairy products
29.7 in that category cheddar cheese has
risen 42 in a year now supermarket and
dairy manufacturers say that Rising
input costs things like the cost of fuel
and wages have forced them to raise
checkout prices for things like milk
cheese and butter if you dig under the
Bonnet something else seems to be
happening new analysis by the Sky News
data team tells a bit more of a
complicated story so the input costs for
dairy manufacturers has risen but
nowhere near as much the price is
they're charging to retailers in yellow
and the price is that retailers have
charged to Consumers that's been rising
even more look at those graphs on the
left you can see that in recent months
those prices the inputs they have
started to fall started to Flatline but
the consumer prices continue to rock it
and we can look at those input prices in
a bit more detail you can see just how
much energy ingredients they were really
high but they have been coming down so
shouldn't the price of food come down
too
well the head of the national Farmers
Union warned that the pain is here to
stay I think it's about fairness in that
supply chain farmers are not going to be
able to keep producing food if they're
not getting a fair return for the costs
that they are facing into and we're
seeing effectively 50 percent cost
inflation for food producing businesses
so it's about everybody sharing that
pain she was speaking at a special
Summit for the food industry at Downing
Street government is supporting people
on the lowest income with the household
support fund payments have been going
out to people in order to help with that
particular cost of living challenge but
more broadly of course we're seeing
changes to an energy cost scene then
start to come down that's critical for
the food industry as well new inflation
figures come out next week and the Sky
News dates team will be looking at why
consumer prices are rising even while
the inputs are falling the government
says that food inflation isn't going
away soon bad news for all of us buying
Our Daily Bread Tom Cheshire Sky News
the Prime Minister has lobbied other
European nations for a change in rules
which have so far blocked deportation
flights to Rwanda at a meeting in
Iceland of the Council of Europe the
continent's human rights organization Mr
sunac has been trying to force the
migration issue onto an agenda which has
been otherwise dominated by the war in
Ukraine and correspondent Ali Fortescue
joins us from the Icelandic Capital
Reykjavik
Jillian this is the start of a huge week
for Rishi sunak on the world stage he
arrived in Iceland this morning he is
already leaving this evening heading
back to London um we'll be picking up
the Press Lobby and flying to Japan for
the G7 tomorrow all of these big world
stage events are an opportunity for the
prime minister to look statesmanly to
look relaxed amongst world leaders but
so often this isn't about the prime
minister's International image this is
about a domestic message sending a
message back home and that is exactly
what we saw from refusernac today
hasn't happened for more than a decade
the Council of Europe created to protect
democracy after the second world war
holding a summit a year since Russia was
expelled
president zelenski you have the floor
there is one clear subject on the agenda
and one leader everyone wants to hear
from we are trying very hard to improve
the protection of our people and I thank
all the countries and leaders who help
us to improve our air defense
all together we are showing what our 100
men
and what the power of the Free World
means today the UK joined other
countries signing up to an International
Register of Damages recording harm
caused by Russian aggression today we
are facing the greatest threat to
democracy and the rule of law on our
continent but on the world stage
domestic politics is often at play too
we need to do
to cooperate across borders and across
jurisdictions to end illegal migration
and stop the boats
the council already plays a vital role
but I urge leaders to consider how we
can go further
because we know what we can achieve
together
and this is a prime minister in trouble
at home Griffey sunak has been weakened
by a dire set of local election results
he wants to use this as an opportunity
on the world stage to send a message
that he is tough on immigration back
home he knows he is facing pressure from
the right of his party do you think you
can actually achieve something with
European leaders today or is this just
rhetoric for domestic consumption well
well actually the the UK has a long
track record of leading and being at the
heart of these conversations on camera
the meetings were friendly
off camera the Prime Minister met with
the president of the European Court of
Human Rights he urged reform to stop
interventions like this one the Rwanda
flight controversially grounded last
year by a European judge but it's not
clear there's any willingness for change
elsewhere in Europe
principles in our DNA and we want to be
more efficient to fight against snuggles
[Music]
The Diplomatic ritual the Cozy European
lineup it all sends a message striking
the right tone over the coming days
abroad and at home where it be easy for
Rishi sidak
I think one of the big questions today
was was this a prime minister that
appeared to be among friends or on the
fringes and the sense you got is that on
Ukraine we are the Rishi sunak is a
prime minister in a country that has
been leading the charge but on
immigration it was a different story
this was what Richard Knight wanted to
talk about and it didn't seem I have to
say like the audience here was
particularly receptive but as I say that
didn't really matter because this was
rhetoric for domestic consumption I
don't think anyone today expected a big
European breakthrough on immigration
okay Ali thank you
three men who ran a global passport
service for future tips have been
sentenced to more than a combined 17
years in prison their two decade-long
operation obtained documents for the
Most Wanted murderers gun Smugglers and
Drug traffickers before they were
eventually caught our crime
correspondent Martin brunt reports
Anthony beard recruiting an identity
donor persuading a man to sell him his
passport the first step in the scam
Step 2 beard meeting a man who wants to
buy the passport a fugitive drug
trafficker
three was the clever bit Anthony beard
took the passport he'd just bought and
applied for a new one using the
fugitives photograph he claimed the
original passport had been damaged or
lost so long as the fugitive looked more
or less like the original passport
holder the scam worked
many of Britain's most wanted fugitives
bought the documents known as Foggs
fraudulently obtained genuine passports
the passport would be a Golden Ticket
whether you're wanted or whether you
want to go in and out the country uh not
seen by obviously law enforcement or by
borders it would be absolutely key to
running organized criminal Network
internationally and across borders it's
absolutely key to their business their
business structure come back to
beard used a High Street shop to print
out the photos of his customers waiting
for passports Christopher zetek was the
go-between he found the buyers through
his contacts with organized crime groups
in London and Scotland
he and beard were bugged discussing a
potential passport customer
a piece of arms
arms elimination for application
cannabis trafficker Jamie a court bought
a passport while hiding in Spain he was
once a suspect in the Stephen Lawrence
murder gun Runner Richard Burdette a
fugitive in Holland and cocaine Smuggler
Michael moogan in Dubai also used the
gang's passports at court Anthony beard
was jailed for six years and eight
months the judge said the gang had
enabled very Wicked sophisticated and
violent criminals to evade Justice
zetec was jailed for eight years Alan
Thompson described as the gang's dog's
body got three years the home office
said the sentences demonstrated the
government's commitment to tackle and
dismantle criminal gangs threatening
Public Safety for profit
Martin brunt Sky News at reading Crown
Court
the head of Scotland's prosecution
service has refused to say whether a
search warrant for Nicholas sturgeon's
home was deliberately delayed until
after she left office Lord Advocate
Dorothy Bain Casey who leads the crown
office was questioned by Sky News after
it emerged that her organization was
made aware of the police request to raid
the former first Minister's home two
weeks before it was given the green
light our Scotland correspondent
Connelly's reports it was the
extraordinary moment the home of
Scotland's former first Minister was
swarming with police
the day Nicholas sturgeon's husband was
detained by detectives investigating SMP
finances ex-chief executive Peter Morrow
later released without charge eventually
support from the last poll and it shows
that labor has fallen behind weeks
before the Sky News debate was in full
flow as the candidates in the race to
replace sturgeon fought live on TV the
stakes were high
and now this document obtained from
police Scotland shows what was happening
behind the scenes at the time it
suggests officers made a formal request
to prosecutors to search the home of the
former first Minister while the SNP
contest was still going on but crucially
it wasn't given the green light until
Hamza Yusuf was installed as the new
leader and the race was over
the head of Scotland's prosecution
service refused to tell Sky News whether
this was a deliberate delay
did you know about it personally
the shrine office and procreator fiscal
service Dorothy being is Scotland's most
senior law officer but also sits in the
Scottish government cabinet as Chief
legal advisor if push comes to shop
we're going to off top of judge's latest
inquiry we simply cannot have political
interference in the legal and justice
system in Scotland I'm disappointed that
the Lord Advocate hasn't been quite
clear and recruited this uh this seems
to give legs to the suggestion that
somebody in the clown office has slowed
down a prosecution or investigation
rather and that is simply unacceptable
prosecutors say Dorothy Bain has nothing
to do with cases where politicians are
involved but questions are mounting and
the police investigation is not over
Conor Gillis Sky News Edinburgh
two poultry workers have tested positive
for bird flu in England as part of the
UK Health Security Agency testing
program the cases are believed to be
linked to the exposure of sick Birds on
a single Poultry Farm where the two
people had recently worked both have
since tested negative for the virus and
there were no signs of human to human
transmission
Essex police are investigating an
allegation of serious sexual assault
against the MP Julian Knight the
allegation was referred by the Met
police who had previously shelved their
investigation into the MP for solihull
Mr Knight who has been suspended by the
conservative party has denied what he
called a false and malicious accusation
a man and a woman who were found dead in
a house in Huddersfield have been named
by West Yorkshire police Katie higton
and Stephen Harnett were founded a
property in Dalton on Monday excuse me
Monday morning a 34 year old man remains
in police custody on suspicion of their
murders
the schools Minister has said he will
look into concerns that last week's SATs
for year six pupils were too difficult
parents and teachers complained about
the reading exam with one that teaches
Union saying that even staff struggled
to understand the questions Skies Becky
Johnson has been getting the views from
the classroom in Stafford
I'd consider myself quite a good reader
so and even I found it quite hard myself
so I was panicking I was like I'm not
going to be able to finish so I was
sitting there like
I'm not going to be able to pass or I'm
not going to get the grade I expected
some questions I did leave and when I
went back I had to skim read and I
couldn't find them they're talking about
their SATs reading test I try not to get
too stressed but inside I was like
screaming it was much more difficult
than pupils or teachers had prepared for
and left some children in tears some of
them were quite distraught really
because it just wasn't what they were
expecting I think it was one of the
trickiest ones that I've ever seen in my
time here we can't show the test as some
pupils could still be sitting it this
week but we've been told that children
had to read
3443 words of text and questions one of
the longest SATs reading tests ever it
means a child reading at the minimum
speed for that age would spend 38
minutes and 14 seconds reading out of
the hour allocated so they'd have just
34 seconds to answer each question
the content of the test has also been
criticized it included cultural
references and expressions that would
have made it difficult for some children
to understand and the way some questions
were worded left even teachers wondering
what it was getting at
many parents are unhappy some of the
girls are crying and I believe the
teacher said it was harder than previous
years it's quite harsh for them really
to have that extra pressure put on them
after hundreds of complaints the schools
Minister has agreed to look into it the
stanzan testing agency was conduct the
SAS test they test these tests uh over
many years they test them with children
and they are assured that it was the the
right test for the children this year
challenging of course because it has to
test a whole range of abilities but I'll
certainly be looking at the test as I do
every year when the tests are available
to the public the head teacher of this
school near Stafford wants the
government to go further so what I'd
like to say is some adjustment in the
marking some flexibility in their
approach to looking at the questions and
potentially lowering the pass marks SATs
matter to schools it's how they're
ranked in league tables it'll be an
anxious wait until July when they get
the results Becky Johnson Sky News
Staffordshire
the creator of chat GPT has warned U.S
lawmakers that regulation of artificial
intelligence is essential Sam Altman the
CEO of openai told the US Congress that
the influence of AI incoming U.S
elections is a significant concern
we're going to face an election next
year and these models are getting better
I think this is a significant area of
concern I think there's a lot there's a
lot of policies that companies can
voluntarily adopt and I'm happy to talk
about what we do there
I do think some regulation would be
quite wise on this topic I think people
are able to adapt quite quickly when
Photoshop came onto the scene a long
time ago you know for a while people
were really quite fooled by photoshopped
images and then pretty quickly developed
an understanding that images might be
photoshopped this will be like that but
on steroids
yeah
well our U.S correspondent Mark Stone
joins us from Washington now and Mark
how unusual is it for the creator of
this technology to to ask for
intervention to ask to be regulated
well it's unusual for for anyone to come
here uh from from a tech firm and say
look regulate us more usually
politicians are used to to people coming
here saying um cut the red tape free us
up allow Innovation but not this time it
really was striking uh Sam Altman a man
who was at the heart of the the
revolution that is AI I'm coming here
and saying look there are so many good
things that AI can do but there are so
many really scary things that AI can do
as well and what struck me was that he
said there are lots of things we know
that AI can do that might not be all
that great but there are so many known
unknowns as they're described things
that we just don't understand yet about
AI technologies that it can impact the
the way it can impact our lives in so
many different ways and he was calling
clearly for uh regulation here at one
point he he referenced the iaea the
nuclear regulator Global nuclear
regulator and he said that there needs
to be something things similar something
Global for artificial intelligence and
what I was also struck by was that there
was bipartisan agreement on both sides
of the aisle here they recognized that
yes there needs to be regulation that
that they are behind Europe only just
behind Europe is hardly a a way and
ahead on on AI regulation but they are
ahead of the United States so a very
very interesting few hours on Capitol
Hill where I think lots of lots of
thought went into what can be done and
what struck me too was just how much we
don't yet know about the damage and the
dangers of AI and Microsoft today has
warned
um that that AI is able now beginning to
be able to to reason like human beings
and I think the prospect of that really
is frightening we could be trying to
regulate something that's smarter than
we are
interesting mark thank you